Always pay it forward. That's my motto. You know and cuz that any given moment one of us could need a helping hand
Like now, you two, total strangers, you know you're short on cash and then someone just steps out of the blue and helps out
in a totally random way, am I right
Uhuh. Okay.
Have we met? No. No. I'm a complete and total stranger
Right
Okay. All right.
Oregon Trail shout-out how about the ending of that episode so the episode itself was obviously a love letter to
classic 90s flash TV series a lot of the references
They made were dedicated to that but also to the idea of
Family trickster family versus flash family so that gives you a better idea
For what was going on at the end of the episode of jitters, so I'll try to explain everything
But there was some stuff from behind the scenes that posted that I'll try to avoid posting till later this week
Just because it is a little bit spoilery
So I'll try to stick to what we know from this episode. General spoilers for episode 11
if you haven't seen it yet. So top 10 WTF comic book Easter eggs as we go along starting with number 10
Everybody's dealing with Barry being in prison first you get the shot of Barry trying to clean up the prison riot without using his powers
in a really obvious way.
Just giving you an idea for how he's going to serve his time, so he will be using his powers
but only in really extreme situations when he's trying to save people's lives or avoid just all-out
Prison war which was what was going on at the beginning of the episode?
But the idea is is that he's gonna have to serve his time
The only way he's gonna get out is if they can prove to the judge that there was something
Funky going on so like we've talked about before
There are a lot of lines of dialogue that are essentially teeing up things that they'll pay off later
And one of those things was is that Joe and Cecile will have a meeting with the judge later that might happen in a later
Episode it might happen next week. Some of the things they set up they pay off right away but some stuff
They just see for way off down the road like at the very end of the episode when the very clearly
Speedster girl from the future is writing down those Flash symbols that Barry was writing when he came out of the Speed Force
Number 9, another marvel spiderman reference. A whole bunch of Marvel references this year in addition to Caitlin being like the Hulk we have
your friendly neighborhood elongated spider-man
So this is basically the episode that gives him the comic-book name in a version of his comic book costume
They changed it just a little bit
I think because his comic book costume looks so close to the Flash's red costume and they want to differentiate them a little bit
So it's a little closer to the silver comic book costume, which is from the classic comics
But you understand how they like modernize certain thing like when prank came back
This is what her classic 90s costume looked like just you know hilarious looking spandex
So obviously everybody gets an update
you can definitely tell they went above and beyond to show you how his powers work, what his weaknesses are, just to give you an
Idea that there are things that can hurt him he's not completely indestructible even though
They make all kinds of references to kryptonite xenomorph blood. It's hilarious
How much of a movie fan that Harrison wells from earth-2 is and the fact that they have the bubble gum the Cisco loves so much
that went out 20 years ago on our earth, which is really more of a metaphor for the original series
Which I'll explain in a second. So a lot of the jokes about things that died out 20 years ago like the toy stores
That's a reference for the original series going off the air 20 plus years ago, but number 7 welcome back Axl Walker trickster
So remember back during season 1 we learned that Mark Hamill's James Jessie trickster
Was the original version of the character from the 90s series who had just been rotting in prison ever since the trial of the trickster
Which actually wound up being the series finale because they cancelled the show after that
but that was also the episode that introduced the prank character and
Because we're doing the trial of the flash, the trial of the trickster
There's just so many Easter eggs
So it's just ripe for the plucking that they do an episode like this right after they do the trial of the flash episode
So the whole idea is is that after that he goes to prison
Rots, then gets out during season one of the flash, is broke out by the axle Walker trickster
Then does the whole Star Wars Darth Vader. "I am your father," but up to that point
We really don't hear from his mother who is now
Officially confirmed to be the prank character who was sort of the Harley Quinn to James Jessie's trickster
But I just did a video sort of explaining her history about how she predates the Harley Quinn character
So she was like Harley Quinn before there was a Harley Quinn. Number 6 though
This is actually really important for the future so if you didn't see mark Hamill was tweeting about the episode
He's been busy with Star Wars press because The Last Jedi
Obviously he's getting ready to go back and do Episode 9 really soon - so yes 100%
I think that he'll come back for another episode, but because of the way Prank was talking about him
"He doesn't care about our family Axl he broke out of prison a year ago
And he hasn't been seen since, he hasn't contacted us or tried to come back"
He's out in the wild somewhere so he could always come back for a Luke vs.
Vader trickster family episode so if you haven't watched the original series
There's this funny story that Mark Hamill tells about how basically his character James Jesse on the original series
Treated Prank like complete crap like he walked all over her and she was completely devoted to him so when Prank is talking about how
Axl's father does not care about them
"I'm the one that raised you while your father was out getting thrown in prison all the time trying to commit crime"
This is sort of an inside joke about how much of a dirtbag the James Jesse character was originally. Like Joker mistreats Harley Quinn
But it was way worse on that 90s flash TV series
So they're just teeing up the idea that
James Jesse will be a villain for Axl and in the comics if you guys didn't know Jeff Johns actually wrote this cool battle that
The two versions of the trickster had in the comics that I think that they could do
but in the comics
they're not related. The TV show set that up with the Darth Vader reveal during season 1
But still in the comics all it is is
Axl just steals all of James Jesse's tricks, his costumes, and takes the name so they become enemies
But eventually Axl does finally become the official version of the trickster
So I think we'll slowly see that happen on the TV show when Mark Hamill is available for another episode
But like I said when they go back to that abandoned toy factory because she's like this chemist
She's the heir to the fortune of this toy company gadzooks. Cisco's like "No you don't have the gum," Harrison Wells is like "Yes,
We do, we still have the gum on Earth-2." They're sort of making the joke that the original flash TV series
Which went out 20 plus years ago like the gum did on the TV show is still running
So it's just a fun way of saying that on Earth-2 the classic flash TV series never got cancelled
But number 5 meet Goldberg just another wrestler on the TV show we're gonna have to have some sort of wrestler team-up
Maybe for a Fight Club 3.0 or 4.0 at some point
He is a comic book character on the TV show he tells Barry that his real name is Dave
But in the comics his real name is Doofus P Ratchet
So they're just using the name and making a couple of jokes about him being this giant dumb strong person
But if it wasn't clear what his relationship with Barry's father was when he was back in prison
Preceding season one is that he basically had some sort of condition that needed to be operated on no one would do it
But Barry's father because he was a surgeon agreed to do it and saved his life, so now Barry's officially made a new friend
He's gonna help protect him even though Barry
Technically doesn't need help being protected because he's using his super speed. The takedown in that fight was pretty hilarious too
So he's using his powers, but in really subtle ways the really funny thing though
He has this line of dialogue where he says "Like father, like son"
after the fights over because Barry took down those criminals
so one is a bit of a joke that Barry's father was a good fighter because he's a big guy John Wesley Shipp is a
pretty big guy
But also like father like son
As in, Grant Gustin is playing the flash Barry Allen whose father was also Barry Allen on the classic TV series
So it's sort of another three levels deep Easter egg. And I'm not a hundred percent
But I do think that a lot of elongated man's
One-liners in his dialogue like when he had really funny phrases were taken from the classic TV series
Like they just lifted dialogue right out of that. Number four
Elongated man versus trickster round one basically him eating all those weapons
Then almost getting melted like the Wicked Witch of the West is just a way of showing you that he will have a weakness that
Will probably come back around later this season
He's mostly indestructible against kinetic damage and blast damage
So like he can eat bombs he can take bullets throwing stars basically anything you could throw at him
But we get our big dark night rises Easter Egg when Barry talks about his time to rise
Inmate three five six two definitely feels like an easter egg
But I couldn't find any reference to any particular comic book or anything like that, but then they roll back into action
I love that Caitlin's Hulk out phrase is Alexey LaRoche her childhood bully so all they had to do is just say that and instantly
She hooks out
But I absolutely love when Irish throws him that tiny little case and he opens it up Pulp Fiction
Style like it's the briefcase from Pulp Fiction only miniaturised. It's basically his suit that he's looking at when he says groovy
He's quoting Bruce Campbell from Evil Dead so sick movie reference
But number three obviously family trickster versus team flash
I love the way they have this set up to they basically do the same thing during the original flash 90s series
So they were trying to recreate a moment like that where you have team flash strapped into this gear
But on the original series it was them trying to scramble
Flash's brain so that he would turn evil and start helping the trickster out. On this series
It was all about melting them with acid
But if you don't remember Beebo, there were a whole bunch of Beebo Easter eggs for Legends of Tomorrow
Because it was the MacGuffin of an episode where it basically got sent back in time and started to be worshipped as a God of
War so if you weren't sure what was going on with Beebo that was just a running plot gag that they carried over from Legends
Of Tomorrow. But number two, Elongated Man of course gets his comic book name
I was surprised that he gave it to himself in the way that they spin the newspaper is just like the 90s flash TV series
during that press conference
They actually played the classic trickster music from the end of the trial of the trickster episode in the 90s series
So they ended both of those episodes in
Relatively the same way with you know very comedic Spade like they tilted the camera into kind of a Dutch angle
But obviously, number one, we have to freak out about Dawn Allen, or you know we could call her future speedster
but it does feel like it's Dawn Allen. Picking up the bill at jitters and
Implying that she is from the future like "Oregon Trail
It's a classic," but it's really not that much of a classic because it's from the 80s
So they want to be a little ambiguous about it
But here's the thing she's writing the same Speed Force symbols that Barry was writing when he came out of the Speed Force
But if you're not absolutely
Convinced that she belongs to Barry and Iris, like one, she sort of looks like she's mixed race
She looks like she could be the daughter of someone who was an african-american female in a white male
But also she talks the same way that Barry talks the first time he appeared on arrow that really quick
excitedness about his speech
She has a really technical mind like Barry has she's talking about all these big science concepts
In this really excited way like even Cisco isn't talking that fast
And he's one of the smartest people on Team Flash like he's like "okay
That's great nice shirt, loved, Oregon Trail"
But here's the thing a lot of people are wondering if that means that she might be a version of Bart Allen
Instead of being Dawn West because Bart Allen is always portrayed as being this really excitable member of the Flash family
But he's Barry's grandson not his daughter
But a lot of that gets into why Iris might potentially get powers briefly later this season and the Easter Egg is in the fact
That Cecile's pregnancy is going to cause her to get powers temporarily. So with Iris
Temporarily gets powers it might be because she's pregnant and because we met the wedding caterer
Total stranger never met this person before that she is Barry and Iris' daughter Dawn
Allen so remember they did have the tornado twins
So there's a boy
Don Allen. Who knows how they're gonna handle that but I think it all just goes back to we're gonna need more diapers
Reveal at the end of the season. I don't think that we're gonna find out to really like the last couple of episodes
What's really going on but I think we all have a pretty good idea, and I will do a separate video
Just piecing all this information together in a really linear easier to understand way like this is what they're applying
This is what they're setting up
This is who this person actually is
but if there were any other Easter eggs you spot in the episode that I didn't mention in the video just write them in the
comments below
There is a new round of that Flash ring giveaway, all you have to do to enter is just be a subscriber
And share the video using those YouTube tools on the watch page there
And I'll say congratulations to the winner from my last video from a little while ago Christian Lucho
Please private message me so I can get your contact details
I'll name a new winner when I post new Flash tomorrow
But I will also post my Black Lightning
Episode 2 video and we might get a Star Wars Han Solo trailer this week so big stuff happening this week big reveals
Click here to learn a little bit more about the history of the trickster and Iris West
Potentially being a speedster briefly this season and click here for that brand new Black Panther trailer
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight